the miami dolphins heard hold the third
pick in the draft by virtue of the
laramie tunsil trade from labor day
weekend of 2019 couple of first-round
picks and the texans were bad enough
that the pick the dolphins get is the
third overall selection this dolphins
team almost made it to the playoffs they
lost against the buffalo bills in week
17 when they still had a chance to get
in are they a playoff team this year and
and again with seven spots in the afc
it's not as hard as it used to be to be
a playoff team do you think this is the
year they get back
well i i think they've got a good chance
mike but it all depends on tua or
whoever their quarterback is right
they've got to get better quarterback
play i mean he was in and out of the
lineup as a rookie and ryan fitzpatrick
because doesn't look like he's going to
come back so they've got to get more out
of that quarterback position if they
trade for deshaun watson i certainly
like their chances depending on what
they give up for them but this looks
like a defensive team that's ready they
have the receivers that are ready they
need a better running game probably a
little bit better offensive line but it
all comes back to the quarterback
position mike how are they gonna how are
they gonna improve their if they do just
a little bit they're in the playoffs
easily
that whole relief pitcher concept and
that was how brian flores the coach of
the team described it at one point where
ryan fitzpatrick would periodically
enter the game in place of tuatanga
vialoa last time that was used was by
the cardinals in
2007 ish i think it was 2007. matt
leinart would start kurt warner would
come in kurt warner would save the bacon
and then matt leinart would go back in
the game they continued that until
lynette was injured for the year but
this time around you got to ask yourself
will ryan fitzpatrick be back and if not
will there be another quarterback who
hovers over to his shoulder or will he
he be the guy shireen who is expected to
carry it all the way through to the end
and make the magic late in the game that
ryan fitzpatrick did on multiple
occasions that's my real question that's
my concern and i know they made the big
investment into a last year with the
fifth overall pick so they feel
compelled to double down
but
i want to know
what they're going to do at that veteran
quarterback position will it be a
veteran will it be a younger guy will it
be a true backup or will it be a relief
pitcher if i'm tua i prefer not to have
a relief pitcher but if i'm a dolphins
fan i'm going to be relieved to know
that there's potential help in the event
that tues struggles in a given game
yeah no question about it mike they have
to address
that position whether it's with ryan
fitzpatrick or someone else and i do
think brian fitzpatrick's gone i think
he'll get a starting job somewhere when
you start to look at this
these free agent quarterbacks jameis
winston
andy dalton
ryan fitzpatrick why not i mean he
started for eight teams he can go start
for for a night team somewhere else
i don't think there are 32 quarterbacks
in the nfl who are better than him same
discussion that that we had with cam i i
do think he can start somewhere be that
bridge quarterback for somebody so
whatever team that is wherever that is
but the dolphins do have to get some
insurance behind too there's no question
about that
here's my problem with ryan fitzpatrick
once you go all in and believe in him he
inevitably craters and then he gets
benched and then he gets back in for
some reason and then he's great again
and then once you say hey he's finally
gotten it he's finally figured it out
that's when it goes the other way it's
confounding but that's how it tends to
happen for ryan fitzpatrick and i i
don't know that there's going to be a
starting job for him when the dust
settles it could be that he's that guy
who
looks like the starter and is at the top
of the unofficial depth chart from
middle of march until end of april and
then in comes a first-round draft pick
as a rookie and it's ryan fitzpatrick as
the backup eventually all over again
although i don't know that that's an
ideal solution if i'm a team that's
bringing in
a first round quarterback do i want to
have a guy hovering who may tempt me
to to yank the rookie out of the game
that there is potential damage to that
that psyche of the quarterback when he
is benched as a rookie and you could
spin it however you want but it doesn't
happen very often
and i just wonder how two is going to
come out of that experience and if they
are going to have somebody on board who
will be in a position to potentially
supplant tua on a game-by-game
case-by-case basis credit to brian
flores he was able to pull it off he was
able to not create issues in the locker
room we heard nothing about it and maybe
there were issues but he has that team
under his thumb to the point where no
one talks about it but you do have to
wonder at one point when you're using
two different quarterbacks is everybody
on board with this is everybody just
just coincidentally feeling the same way
or or just you know so conditioned to
defer to the coach that they're able to
set aside their own personal feelings
that would be rare if it's the latter
because at some point the personal
feelings are going to come out in the
locker room in the weight room on the
practice field why is two of the starter
why don't we just go with fitzpatrick
why are they yanking to a i i just think
that it's better for everyone if they
make two of the starter and find a true
backup and let it play out and if it
works it works and if it doesn't then
you move on and you try to find a
franchise quarterback somewhere else
sharing
yeah and you know you talk about ryan
fitzpatrick i think it worked because of
him because of his mindset because he
never questioned why am i not starting
even when i'm the better guy to start
for this team he never did that and
that's why i think you're comfortable
signing him and then drafting a guy in
the first round and maybe ryan
fitzpatrick starts out the season as he
did in miami as your starter and you
pencil in all right on the bye week our
our quarterback our rookie quarterback
has had enough time in that period to
get ready and and after the bye week
we're gonna start him and that's what
the dolphins had planned of course their
bye week got moved around and pushed up
and and he started at a different point
than than maybe he would have otherwise
but we're again mike probably not going
to have an off season so to think that a
rookie quarterback is going to come in
and light it up joe burrow did that to
an extent
but you wouldn't mind having your
quarterback sit behind a guy like a ryan
fitzpatrick or a tyrod taylor there's
only a certain number of guys there that
are good for that but i think both of
those guys are really good quarterbacks
that would would handle that and the
rookies could handle that behind them
they'd be a good influence on those
rookies mike
one quick point of clarification too the
way i remember it is ryan fitzpatrick
said some things when he was originally
benched for tua that were eye-opening
and i wonder what brian flores did
behind the scenes to get him to knock it
off and just buy in and accept what his
role was going to be because i think i
think fitz was salty at first but then
came around and i it's a credit to brian
flores and the force of his personality
as a head coach where he can get guys to
do what he wants them to do all right
here's what we want to do next one guy
in one guy out in the off season for the
miami dolphins shireen you go first with
your guy who is on his way in in your
estimation
i think they're going to use that third
overall pick mic on a receiver and i'm
going to go with jamar chase and of
course he opted out of the 2020 season
but in 2019 84 catches 1780 yards and 20
touchdowns he would have been probably
the top receiver selected a year ago or
at least in that top tier of receivers
that we saw picked if he had been able
to enter the draft after the 2019 season
and they're gonna have a tough decision
if they decide to go to receiver do you
pick chase or do you pick devonta smith
and i think that's the decision they're
gonna be faced with there with that
third pick but i think either one of
those guys might give them an upgrade at
the receiver position will help to uh
maybe you pick devonta smith just
because he played with tua at alabama
but i think receiver is what they're
looking at with that third pick
i think to get the most out of tua you
need to have a great running game and i
know brian flores comes from new england
where they never had one guy who was the
guy on a on a constant basis but i like
the idea of pursuing aaron jones i saw
someone suggest today that jones is
going to get a 15 million dollar per
year contract that doesn't happen you
don't get big money as a running back
from any team other than the team that
you already played for and became a star
with when you hit the market it's melvin
gordon it's 8 million a year and i think
it could be less than that this year
because of the reduced salary cap so i
think aaron jones isn't going to come
close to 15 million a year may not even
get to 10 million a year and he could be
a guy the dolphins bring in and say
you're our guy you are running and
receiving running back and we're gonna
we're gonna help tua by giving him a
weapon that really can flourish in that
offense and and make it easier for tua
to get the most out of his abilities all
right who's out for the dolphins shireen
well i had ryan fitzpatrick at the top
of my list and i do think he's gone but
we've discussed him so i think center
ted carris is a free agent they're gonna
have to replace him at the center
position and he is gonna be one of the
top centers on the market so however
they do that whether that's through the
draft or free agency or whatever they do
they're going to have to replace uh ted
karis's center and
again that's an invaluable position
because he's a veteran guy and tua needs
a veteran guy at the center position i
don't know that he necessarily needs a
rookie coming in there and trying to set
his protections for him mike
and you know i uh
i believe that no matter whether a team
does have cap space or doesn't have cap
space
this year of a reduced cap environment
is going to prompt teams to take a hard
look at their roster and ask themselves
dollar for dollar is there someone else
out there that i can get
and get out from under a contract that
maybe has a salary that's more than we
want to pay and when i was looking
through what some of these guys were
making bobby mccain is a guy that i
thought you know you just you this is
there's a chance there's a chance that
that he's making enough that he's red
flagged and they think they can find a
replacement elsewhere this gets down to
that actor ripping the name off the back
of the jersey looking only at film and
when you consider how many guys are
going to be flooding the market you can
you can find a way if you choose to do
so to say
we're going to upgrade dollar for dollar
by shedding a contract that maybe has
too much cap space tied to it so that's
just one name that popped out at me when
i was looking through their roster and
looking at their cap numbers this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports